-Welcome back, everybody. We're
hanging out with Jared Leto.
Now, Jared,
last time you were on the show,
we competed in a segment called
"30 Seconds To..."
in honor of your band,
Thirty Seconds to Mars,
where we each had 30 seconds
to complete
a series
of very important challenges.
Well, I think it's time
for a rematch.
This is "30 Seconds To..."
rematch.
-♪ "30 Seconds To..." ♪
-♪ Rematch ♪
-Okay, buddy,
are you ready for this, man?
-I'm so ready. Are you ready?
-I don't know.
-I got to tuck my hair back --
I'm so ready.
I'm...
-I know. I know.
For this first challenge,
we have to use straws
to transport
as many Goldfish Crackers
from one plate to another place
without using our hands.
After 30 seconds, whoever has
moved the most Goldfish wins.
Sound good?
Ready...
set...
go!
♪♪
How's
Jared doing?
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Ah!
Ah-ah-ah-ah!
-Whew, yeah.
You get a little
of that Goldfish dust.
-I think I brought one down.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Sighs ]
-Alright, let's count --
see how many you got there.
I got 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
17.
[ Laughs ]
-22, man.
Come on, now!
-Come on, man.
[ Bell dinging ]
Oh, my gosh.
-Come on!
-Alright.
Round 1 goes to Jared Leto.
-Come on!
-For the next challenge,
we have 30 seconds
to unwrap as many
Hershey's Kisses as possible
while wearing oven mitts.
I think
I have a strategy to this.
-You do?
-Yuh-huh, yeah.
-[ Chuckles ] Okay, okay.
-I'm going for the win, man.
-Ready...set...
-2 for 2.
-...go!
♪♪
Gosh, did not work!
I'm so mad.
[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
That was my strategy.
Oh, God.
Can you use your teeth?
Ooh.
Jamesy, you did one.
How you doing, Jared?
-Oh, man,
what are you talking about?
-[ Breathes sharply ]
Did you crush these?
-This is not a hobby, my friend.
This is not a hobby.
-I got --
I got --
[ Buzzer ]
Alright.
I think I know who probably won
this, but, gosh, I got four.
-[ Chuckles ]
-[ Sighs ] It looks sad, too.
-Wait. You got four?
That's pretty good.
I got one...
-Mm-hmm.
-...two Kisses...
-[ Laughs ] Two Kisses.
-...three Kisses...
-Yeah.
-...four Kisses...
-How many -- five?
-Five!
-Oh, my gosh!
One extra Kiss?!
[ Bell dinging ]
You know what?
I messed up --
my strategy
messed my whole thing up.
I thought I was gonna use,
like, a garlic
and do, like,
a whew, whew, whew,
but then it did not work at all.
Gosh!
On to the next challenge.
For our final challenge,
we have 30 seconds to
wrap ourselves in as much
toilet paper as possible.
Whoever gets the most
toilet paper on their body wins.
-Jimmy, this single-ply, man --
this is like --
-Look, look, we're in --
I know, but, look --
Come on. We'll --
We'll discuss the budget later.
-[ Chuckling ]
Okay. Let's go.
-You ready for this?
-Let's go. I'm ready.
-Ready...set...
-Yeah.
-..go!
♪♪
Oh, it is single-ply.
Darn it.
-I had a strategy. I don't know
if it's gonna work, though.
-Oh, gosh. Mine's just ripping
and tearing off.
This is so...
-Told you -- it's single-ply.
-I know that --
single-ply is a rough...
-Single-ply.
-Darn it. Oh!
I can't even...
Oh, this --
this is cheap toilet paper!
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my gosh.
This is so --
This is ridiculous.
Ohh.
[ Buzzer ]
You're joking.
-It was a close call.
-This is a pretty close call,
'cause I almost did, like,
an "I Dream of Jeannie"
type of thing,
and what you did
was the correct thing.
The winner is...
Jared Leto.
[ Bell dinging ]
Crushed me in this
"30 Seconds To..."
Oh, my goodness.
Jared Leto, everyone, the champ!